- So, this right over here is one way
to represent the number 37.
The number 37 has a three right
over here in the tens place.
So, this three literally
represents three tens.
Notice, this is a ten
here, this is a ten here,
and this is a ten here, three tens or 30.
You see each of these tens,
there's one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Now, the seven is in the ones place.
It literally represents seven ones.
You see that right over here,
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, so you can say that 37
is equal to three tens,
do this in the purple color,
is equal to three tens
plus seven ones.
Now, what if I wanted
to add something to 37?
What would 37
plus two be equal to?
How many tens and how many ones?
Well, let's think about it.
We're now going to add two,
so we're adding two ones,
so we're going to add one and two.
So, now we still have three
tens, so let's write that down.
So we still have three
tens, but now we have
a different number of ones,
we now have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, we now have nine ones.
Another way to think about it is
seven ones plus two ones is nine ones.
So let me write that down.
So, plus nine ones, or another
way to think about it is
37, let me just write it the same way,
37 plus 2 is equal to three tens,
so I can write this as 30
and then nine ones, is equal to 39,
and that's exactly what we have here.
We have 30, this was the three tens,
and then we have nine
ones, which is 39 squares.